como é que vai ser a medicina do futuro
se a gente abrir jornais e revistas
entrar na eterna
especializados com certeza a gente vai
ver imagens como robôs que conseguem
fazer cirurgias
quase sem supervisão de humanos ou
sistemas de inteligência artificial que
conseguem fazer diagnósticos de doenças
super complicados ou até mesmo os órgãos
que são sintetizados artificialmente
para substituir órgãos naturais em
transplantes ou então a nanotecnologia
microrrobôs que são capazes de entrar no
nosso corpo e modificar o
desenvolvimento de doenças através de
alterações do dna ou a nível celular
sem dúvida as tecnologias prometem um
horizonte fantástico para medicina no
futuro
agora eu quero convidar vocês aqui olha
isso de uma outra forma que a forma como
eu convido os estudantes trabalho como
professor do curso de medicina a pensar
tem duas formas que a gente pode olhar
não só para a profissão médica para o
exercício da medicina
mas pra qualquer outra profissão a
primeira é quando a gente entra no curso
numa formação ea gente se pergunta que
tipo de médico no meu caso médica eu
gostaria de ser com certeza quando a
gente responde a essa pergunta olhando
pra dentro da gente vão ver imagens da
nossa própria história dos nossos grupos
sociais e familiares de origem e com
certeza essas imagens de uma medicina
altamente tecnológica e outra
especializada que compõem o que a grande
mídia passa para a gente sobre a
medicina mas eu posso mudar essa
pergunta e é esse convite que eu quero
fazer para vocês de que medicina será
que as pessoas precisam hoje em dia de
medicina a população aqui dessa cidade
desse país e do mundo precisam para isso
a gente precisa parar para olhar como é
que está a situação das pessoas hoje em
dia e se a gente pára pra observar dados
informações que nos conta um pouquinho
de como está a nossa saúde
talvez a gente comece a refletir que não
vai ser um erro
o uso de tecnologia que vai trazer as
melhores respostas
estima se que mais de 50% da morbidade e
da mortalidade prematuras são causadas
por determinante comportamentais e
sociais de saúde tais como tabagismo
tipo de alimentação falta de atividade
física status sócio-econômico
esse é um dado da associação de escolas
médicas american
imaginem vocês 50% das mortes que podem
ser evitadas podem ser evitadas por
questões relacionadas a comportamentos
ea forma como nós vivemos em sociedade
e aqui eu queria chamar a atenção para
uma primeira coisa estou falando de
mortes evitáveis
porque essa é uma primeira pergunta que
a gente deve se fazer
será que a gente está atrás de um modelo
de medicina que nos torne imortais ou
que impeça com que nós envelhecemos
será que esse tipo de medicina que a
gente está querendo será que esse tipo
de medicina que é necessário hoje em dia
ou na medicina que nos convite a olhar
para a morte produz cimento de uma outra
forma
quando eu quero dizer risco
comportamental fatores comportamentais
eu tô falando que só o uso de cigarro
mata cerca de 6 milhões de pessoas por
ano isso significa 11 por cento de todas
as mortes no mundo
quando eu falo de determinantes sociais
eu estou me referindo a dados como esse
um pesquisador da universidade colúmbia
ele procurou investigar como que
questões sociais provocam a morte das
pessoas
e vejam que dados alarmantes que ele
encontrou olhando a situação dos estados
unidos nos anos 2000
duzentos e nenhum 91 mortes por pobreza
e desigualdade de renda
245 mil mortes por baixos níveis
educacionais 176 mil mortes por
segregação racial
isso é maior por exemplo do que as
mortes são causadas por um derrame por
acidentes e trauma ou mesmo uma doença
super comum hoje em dia como diabetes
eu posso olhar porque faz a gente morreu
hoje em dia e posso olhar para algo que
também faz com que a gente perca anos de
vida de inserção social de trabalho de
bem estar com a nossa família
os transtornos mentais e comportamentais
são responsáveis por quase 25% dos anos
perdidos por incapacidade da população
mundial hoje a depressão já é a
principal causa de incapacidade de anos
perdidos por incapacidade no mundo
e aí eu pergunto pra vocês qual será a
medicina do futuro de que medicina as
pessoas precisam hoje olhando para esses
dados se a gente percebe que o grande
desafio talvez não esteja em novas
tecnologias mais uma distribuição justa
e equitativa das tecnologias e dos
conhecimentos em medicina que a gente já
tem disponíveis a nossas mãos
a medicina do futuro pra isso pra ela
deixar de pensar naquilo que a gente
imagina com essa construção dessa
medicina altamente tecnológica
especializada ela precisa ser uma
medicina centrada nas pessoas
esse termo medicina centrada nas pessoas
não termos que eu estou inventando
ele é um termo que foi desenvolvido por
pesquisadores do canadá desde a década
de 80 que justamente começaram a
observar que hoje existe um grande
distanciamento dentro da prática médica
na forma do médico lidar com os aspectos
subjetivos emocionais comportamentais
dos seus pacientes
isso pode ser observado não só na
medicina mas eu acredito em qualquer
profissão parece que de alguma forma a
gente tem medo e que é excluir retirar
da nossa forma de lidar como humanos
as nossas emoções a forma como nós
levamos a vida dos nossos valores nossos
sonhos
todo estudante de medicina sabe
e já escutou falar isso de vários
lugares que se envolver com o paciente
pode ser algo prejudicial para o
tratamento
isso pode afetar a sua objetividade a
sua racionalidade e isso pode
comprometer sua capacidade de
diagnóstico a sua frieza na hora de
intervir um tratamento mas será que isso
é verdade
médicos não devem se envolver
emocionalmente em suas consultas
um pesquisador juntou vários dados de
vários estudos sobre essas questões e
veja que interessante quando médicos não
se envolve emocionalmente com os seus
pacientes nas consultas acontece isso em
30 50 por cento das consultas a médicos
e pacientes não concordam com o
principal motivo que trouxe eles a
consulta o paciente vem se consulta com
você e depois ele sai e você pergunta
pra mim e pra ele o que ele acha que foi
o principal motivo da consulta em metade
das vezes as nossas opiniões são
diferentes 50% dos pacientes saem das
consultas sem entender que os médicos
disseram a eles pensem vocês como
pacientes se isso já não aconteceu não
aconteceu bastante comigo quando o
paciente quando médicos não se envolve
emocionalmente com seus pacientes suas
consultas
obviamente o que vai acontecer baixa
adesão terapêutica
as pessoas quando não têm um contato uma
empatia uma conexão especialmente um
assunto tão delicado e tão caro como a
saúde como seguir um tratamento
resultados clínicos insatisfatórios são
a consequência logo em seguida estresse
esgotamento profissional dos médicos
o médico que não faz contato com as suas
emoções
ele também se esgota profissionalmente
ou ele prefere especialidades médicas
que cada vez menos fazem com que ele
possa lidar com o paciente o que lhe dá
de uma forma super restrita e processos
legais
obviamente se não existe uma relação de
compreensão de comunicação bem
estabelecida e esse desentendimento pode
chegar às vias legais
e à transgenia vejam que dado
interessante dessa empresa de
consultoria na área de medicamentos à
venda de conan zepam no brasil aumentou
de 29 mil caixas em 2007 para 23 milhões
de caixas em 2013
talvez vocês não se eu falar com a
agepan fica mais difícil saber o que é
mas é um ansiolítico que hoje as pessoas
mais usam de uma forma totalmente
equivocada como se fosse um tratamento
de insônia
quando na verdade do ponto de vista
clínico a ge indicações desse
medicamento são altamente restritas e
hoje os médicos diante queixas de
insônia passam esses medicamentos ou de
ansiedade de forma discriminada e eles
provocam três coisas dependência química
as pessoas não sabem mais dormissem
esses remédios perda de memória e pude
me incluir a atenção das pessoas fazem
com que principalmente idosos que tomam
esses remédios caiam e tenham mais
fraturas ou seja quando eu não sei lidar
com as emoções dos meus pacientes e na
alternativa disso eu ofereço remédios
eu estou colocando em risco a vida deles
com a possibilidade
a possibilidade que eu venho trazer para
vocês hoje essa mudança de paradigma a
gente parar pra pensar uma medicina
centrada nas pessoas o que eu estou
chamando centrada nas pessoas têm a ver
com três pontos
o primeiro ponto é que médicos e
pacientes possam cuidar de suas emoções
nesse processo de cuidado da saúde
a questão não é se nós devemos nos
envolver emocionalmente enquanto
profissionais mas como nós devemos nos
envolver emocionalmente com
profissionais e aí eu queria chamar
atenção para três elementos empatia
atenção e compaixão e pra falar desses
três
eu prefiro contar uma história vou sair
do círculo vermelho
eu prefiro contar uma história
e é falar disso teoricamente eu há pouco
tempo tive a experiência de atender o
senhor da faixa de 40 anos que ele
estava vindo aqui ele está vindo a
consulta em função de um quadro de
dengue é uma suspeita de dengue estava
fechado ele estava fazendo vários exames
em função disso é eu olhei os exames
dele e me chamou a atenção que ele tinha
outros exames que não tinham nada a ver
com a dengue é um exame para avaliar o
fígado dele algumas questões do sangue
que não tem nada a ver com desenvolvendo
a dengue
eu perguntei pra ele porque só fez
exames e ele começou a me contar que há
um ano ele vinha sentindo insônia e
muito cansaço durante o dia e que estava
prejudicando muito o trabalho dele
ele estava acompanhado pela esposa e na
hora que eles falaram isso eu antes de
perguntar questões mais objetivas há
quanto tempo como é que essa história eu
deixei um pequeno silêncio porque eu
percebi que o paciente se emocionou um
pouco na hora que ele falou disso ele
deixam d'água eo da esposa do lado dele
não só encheu d'água quando ela começou
a chorar eu fiz exatamente o que estou
fazendo agora aqui com vocês eu parei
parei comecei a olhar para ele
ela disse estou vendo que você tá bem
emocionada e que eu acho muito corajoso
da sua parte aqui numa consulta médica
a expressão dessa emoção se você achar
que pode te ajudar e conta um pouco do
que você está sentindo me conta um pouco
do que está passando com você agora a
paciente chorou mais gente com um pouco
mais de silêncio e aí ela falou eu não
sabia que ele estava passando por isso
há um ano
eu não sabia que meu marido estava há um
ano com insônia e isso estava
prejudicando o trabalho dele
eu achei aquilo estranho mas eu fui
entender melhor
eles moravam juntos eles tinham se
casado há quatro ano e por questões que
tinham a ver com o trabalho e as
demandas familiares deles moravam em
cidades separadas ea início o marido
começou a contar também de uma série de
coisas que estavam fazendo para tentar
resolver essa situação
eu voltei um pouco na história da
insônia mp e perguntei pra ele como é
que esses ônibus eu senti ele falou
de vez em quando de noite o acordo com
os estalidos uma sensação de alerta
eu falei isso não tem nenhum livro de
casos de insônia não existe essa
descrição desse tipo de insônia e aí eu
perguntei pra ele e por que você acha
que vem essa esses estalidos o paciente
falou
são preocupações eu fico preocupado como
é que ela tá lá na cidade dela eu fico
preocupado com jeito da gente poder
ficar juntos e aí a gente conversou um
pouco mais sobre isso
isso não durou 5 a 7 minutos
a consulta
o e no final a gente podia de forma o
dial é afetuoso
mas a gente não chegou nenhuma conclusão
de como é que resolver aquela insônia ou
de como é que a resolver exatamente
aquela as dificuldades que eles tinham
para poder morar no mesmo lugar mas a
expressão e o que eles relataram também
um pouquinho mais no final sinalizado
que só deles ter internalizado aquela
emoção só deles terem conseguido colocar
aquilo pra fora e à esposa descoberto
que o marido já estava passando por aqui
há um ano e que ela poderia ter uma
comida e comunicação melhor com o marido
dela para ajudar a cuidar daquele
problema dele e eles conseguirem lidar
juntos mais unidos com aquela situação
aquilo já apontavam um caminho de como
lidar melhor com aquele cansaço com
aquela história dele então primeiro
cuidar das emoções suas como
profissional e dá aquela pessoa que você
está tendo na sua frente
no caso da gente como médico o seu
paciente segundo lugar
quando a gente fala que a gente pretende
a gente vê que existem fatores
comportamentais que estão associados a
50% das mortes e das doenças graves que
acometem as pessoas no mundo hoje a
gente tem que ter muito cuidado para não
achar que a função nem nossa com um
profissional médico nem de ninguém
ditar as pessoas como elas devem se
comportar o que elas devem fazer como
elas devem levar a vida delas
mas vejam que interessante esse dado de
50% vêm diretamente dos estados unidos
ou seja se o adoecimento leva 50 por
cento é do adoecimento evitável
nesses lugares é causado por
comportamentos
será que mesmo em lugares muito
desenvolvidos só a condição material
garante a nossa capacidade de fazer
escolhas
a chave para a gente fazer escolhas
sobre nosso comportamento se eu tenho um
comportamento que me impede com que eu
viva mais até para usufruir desse dessa
maior quantidade de riqueza material que
eu tenho alguma coisa esquisita e as
pessoas a a capacidade escolhas não vem
só da riqueza material em riqueza
material muitas vezes ela está associada
a vocês e colonizado por um modo de
levar a sua vida que te impede de ver
que tem outras possibilidades
então a nossa responsabilidade com
profissionais da saúde é fortalecer a
capacidade dos nossos pacientes de fazer
escolhas de que eles sejam protagonistas
do próprio cuidado de saúde deles
a medicina se você for ver com muito
detalhe gente ela tem muito pouco
certeza sobre a maior parte das coisas e
nós nos fazemos muitas vezes de doutos
da verdade de uma verdade científica
mente não existe e que no lugar de
compartilhar essas incertezas com os
nossos pacientes nós bancamos de alguém
que pode garantir alguma coisa para eles
quando na verdade não pode
quem de vocês aqui já ouvi falar quando
recebeu uma indicação de um remédio de
um médico dos efeitos colaterais que
aquele remédio traz para você poder
escolher se você prefere o benefício ou
se arriscar que ele ter até efeito
colateral por exemplo segundo ponto
fortalecer a capacidade das pessoas de
fazerem escolhas
agora cuidar das emoções e fortalecer a
capacidade das pessoas de fazer escolhas
precisa de um cenário de uma condição
para exercer a medicina bem particular
esse cenário essa condição é o que a
gente chama em termos técnicos de
atenção primária à saúde
aqui no brasil só o termo meio esquisito
que a gente conhece mais vindo da
discussão da saúde pública do sus
atenção primária à saúde é um modo de se
fazer saúde que considera quatro
aspectos que você tenha acesso direto
universal que todas as pessoas possam
ter uma equipe de saúde e um médico uma
médica responsáveis por cuidar da saúde
daquela pessoa que você não seja visto
de forma fragmentada
quem é que já teve a sensação de que tem
um médico para ver o meu joelho o médico
para ver no coração médico para ver meu
olho o médico para ver minha cabeça e
esses médicos não conversam entre si
sendo que aquilo que eu tomo para mexer
no meu coração pode afetar o meu olho e
pode prejudicar o meu joelho e não tem
ninguém que ver isso tudo junto à
integralidade
a gente precisa de profissionais médicos
com capacidade de olhar para as pessoas
e com e poder resolver até 90% dos
problemas de saúde delas sem ter que
encaminhar ela para outro especialista
porque isso é possível do ponto de vista
técnico
noventa se 90% dos problemas por um
médico capacitado treinado nos
principais problemas de saúde da
população são possíveis de resolver
do seu lado perto de onde você mora
porque não tem um médico que tv do
pré-natal ao cuidado paliativo do ventre
ao túmulo e que esse médico que não vai
resolver tudo com certeza teria
integrado e referenciado com uma equipe
de especialistas de outras
especialidades que possam ajudar a
resolver os 21 10% que ele não possa
resolver na hora
a especialidade capaz de oferecer essa
medicina
chama-se medicina de família e
comunidade países com os melhores
indicadores de saúde do mundo
eles têm de 20 a no caso do canadá por
exemplo 52% dos médicos deles como
médico de família e comunidade do brasil
a gente já tem um número muito tímido e
principalmente no sistema único de saúde
com toda uma série de problemas que a
gente sabe que tem e que muitas vezes
acho que as pessoas achem que essa é uma
prática médica menor
aí aquele médico que fica lá no postinho
só que aquele médico bem capacitado e
capacitado aí não me disse nem só de
família significa ter competências para
exercer essa medicina centrada na pessoa
com esses elementos que estou falando
para vocês
ele pode resolver 90% dos problemas de
saúde da população
qual é a medicina do futuro eu acredito
que não tem uma resposta mas a gente
pode fazer uma aposta que a medicina do
futuro é aquela que vai se apoiar no
reconhecimento de que aquilo que nos
torna humanos não é a nossa capacidade
de nos dividirmos mas é a nossa
capacidade reconhecemos que nós
dependemos uns dos outros foi sempre
isso que levou a nossa espécie biológica
à frente reconhecer que o nosso bem
estar individual depende do bem estar
das pessoas que estão aqui nessa sala do
seu lado
depende do bem estar das pessoas que
você vai atender na sua profissão como
médico como qualquer outra profissão
depende do bem estar de todas as pessoas
do mundo e que se a gente pode fazer
alguma coisa hoje pela saúde das pessoas
ela não precisa aguardar robôs ela não
precisa aguardar nanotecnologia
ela precisa olhar para as emoções e pôs
sonhos de cada um de nós temos uma
sociedade onde nós realmente encontramos
um espaço de realização e de felicidade
que só é possível se isso foi
distribuída de forma equitativa e justa
entre todos nós